-We are hanging out with 14-time
Major League
all-star Alex Rodriguez!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughing ]
Oh, how cool, man.
Alex and I
are about to go head-to-head
in a game
of Egg Russian Roulette.
Higgins, do you want to explain
how this works?
-Of course, James!
[ Laughter ]
Here in my hand
I have one dozen eggs.
Eight...
-Aw, man.
-...of them
have been hard-boiled.
Four of them are still raw.
You and Alex will take turns
smashing an egg
upon the top of your head.
[ Laughing ]
You won't know
which eggs are raw
and which are the hard-boiled...
[ Laughs ]
...until you smash them!
And once you choose an egg,
you must smash that egg
upon your head.
No put-backs.
-Okay, of course.
-First one to smash
two r-r-r-raw eggs --
[ Laughter ]
-Jimmy, the helmet
might be a bit much.
-Oh, yeah.
The helmet's a bit much.
I think it --
-I think I'm a bit much.
-Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
-Alex, as a guest of our show,
you shall choose the first egg.
-I'm gonna get me
some batting gloves on.
-Oh, snap.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God!
That is the coolest.
This is fantastic
to see this happen.
-All right. Am I first?
-Yes.
-Oh, my gosh.
This is unbelievable.
I love that you're doing this.
-Choose wisely.
-Like Michael Jackson.
-That's the one,
Michael Jackson right there.
Go for it, man.
-Here we go.
-Good l-u-u-u-uck!
-What does it feel?
What does it feel?
-It feels lucky.
[ Light laughter ]
Here we go.
Oh, my gosh.
I hope my girls
are not watching.
They're sleeping.
-Yeah! You did it!
That's good, that's good.
That's it -- hard-boiled.
-Whew! Whew.
Good.
-You got away with that one.
-Good, good, good, good, good.
Whew!
-James.
-I'm just gonna go right for it.
Here we go.
-Go for it!
-Yeah. How does it feel?
How does it feel?
-Feels great, man.
Good to see you.
Thank you so much
for coming on the show, man!
You're the best!
-Aah!
[ Laughing ]
[ Audience groans, applause ]
-That is ridiculous.
That sounded
like it was hard-boiled.
liked it was hard-boiled!
Oh, God.
That sounded
like it was hard-boiled, man.
-Oh, my goodness.
-Aw, man.
You can't tell the difference.
-All right, here we go.
Here we go.
-I'm so mad.
That was the first one
out of the box.
-All right, here we go.
I'm gonna do it just like you --
nice and quick,
not thinking about it too much.
Boo--
Ohh!
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-Did you see it?
Slow-motion.
-Oh!
-Look at slow-motion.
-Ohh!
-Oh, my God.
Dude, this is --
[ Laughing ]
That was the best way.
I didn't think
anyone would do that.
Oh, my God.
It didn't feel
like it was raw, right?
-That was a home run.
[ Laughter ]
-All right, I'm gonna go
with this one?
No, this one.
-Oh-ho-ho!
-This one.
-Oh, yeah.
-[ Laughing ]
-Oh, baby.
-[ Breathes deeply ]
Thank you so much
for coming on the show, man.
-[ Laughing ]
-Good luck
with the All-Star game.
July 11th, on Fox.
-Oh!
-No.
No, no! No, you're good.
You're good, you're good,
you're good.
[ Applause ]
All right.
-I'm still in it.
-All right.
-It's a barn burner.
-Jimmy, I just want
to say you're a great host.
Thanks for inviting me
and making a fool out of me.
Here we go --
1, 2, 3 -- ohh!
-Aha-ha-ha!
[ Audience groans, applause ]
-I got the win!
I won!
I won.
I love this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're the best, man.
-Oh, I love it.
Yeah!
-Alex Rodriguez, everybody!
Nick Kroll
joins us after the break.
Stick around, everybody!
I'm the champ!
Oh, my gosh!